e
[Música]
o que tiver a mente quando você pensa em
aparência bom eu achava que isso dizia
apenas do estilo da roupa os aspectos
físicos mas na verdade eu fui percebendo
que se diz dia questões mais profundas
entre o que mostramos e quem realmente
sol mas porque será que é tão difícil
expressar mos que realmente somos bom
isso me faz pensar numa história que eu
gostaria de compartilhar com vocês na
minha família eu sempre foi tida como o
ideal do que você deveria ser uma pessoa
tranquila
educado inteligente e tudo mais me
usavam de referência para que os outros
também deveriam ser só que claro que
isso eu fui descobrir muito tempo depois
que foi de um se por acaso não acredito
que não tenho feito ali de forma
consciente você pode estar se
perguntando aí assim como eu também me
perguntei durante muitos anos da minha
vida o que que é de ruim onde errado e
ser referência como algo bom claro que
isso não é inteiramente ruim pelo
contrário eu consegui várias coisas na
minha vida isso me ajudou me informar em
quantas pessoas você que ao longo do
tempo eu fui percebendo que isso acabou
sendo algo ruim também e acabou virando
um fardo na minha vida eu achava que
para manter todos esses postos que eu
comentei com vocês eu não podia errar eu
não podia falhar se eu fizesse isso eu
não seria mais aquela Núbia e na medida
que eu fui crescendo ali nas minhas
amizades eu eu sentia que eu vim aqui tá
sempre ali disponível que eu sempre
tinha que saber como ajudar as minhas
amigas e que se eu não conseguisse estar
presente algum encontro E essas pessoas
iriam ali esquecer de mim ou não fazendo
questão muito da minha presença então eu
me sentia muito culpada se eu não
conseguia ajudar elas e estar presente
Inclusive eu eu cheguei a mesma igreja
em si a diversas vezes para poder ajudar
uma outra pessoa a verdade é que assim
eu sempre fui uma pessoa muito aberta
para o mundo sempre tive muitos amigos
amigas sair me divertir bastante mas de
me conhecer ali no fundo os dramas né
Para Além da realidade sempre foram
pouquíssimas pessoas
bom E aí não quer mais se nos
relacionamentos amorosos eu não preciso
nem dizer né Isso foi uma catástrofe
porque eu me relacionava assim de forma
autêntica porque eu sempre fui com muita
opiniosos e tudo mais só que eram
relações rasas superficiais então não
passava ali do primeiro do segundo
encontro e a verdade é que eu tinha
muito medo ali de me apaixonar então eu
acabava me boicotando em várias
possíveis relacionamentos ali só que
como eu sempre foi uma pessoa boa
ouvinte e ele é muita coisa sobre
relacionamento e observava new que as
minhas amigas acabavam fazendo de errado
eu achava eu criava Na verdade é um
script de como que tinha que acontecer
as coisas como que tinha que acontecer
as relações aqui que eu deveria fazer
como que isso deveria acontecer só que
eu já adianto que isso nunca deu certo
foi isso não dá certo
Oi e aí e um desses relacionamentos eu
lembro de uma vez eu acho que a gente
tava ali no segundo Encontro e a pessoa
estava sendo toda fofa falando olha a
gostaria de sair de novo né Vamos sair
eu mandei algo do tipo olha podemos sair
sim só que eu não tô interessado em
namorar eu tô de boa tô tranquila eu
quebrei o clima ali sim ou eu com
certeza né E também não precisa adiantar
aqui eu acabei me apaixonando pela
pessoa e isso virou ator da minha vida
porque eu comecei a gostar dela só que
eu demorei muito tempo para poder
assumir tanto para pessoa aí e
principalmente para mim que eu tava
gostando dessa pessoa e vai ser deixar
as coisas ali de incluir e acontecendo
eu me agarrei aquela aparência de que eu
tava bem resolvida com isso de que eu
não me e se a pessoa Science com outras
e de que
que eu eu poderia lhe
ter um relacionamento deixar as coisas
fluírem né eu achava que isso era ser
uma pessoa bem resolvida a verdade é que
esse ideal da perfeição que eu acabei
internalizando me custou muito caro e eu
achava que eu nunca teria um
relacionamento por conta disso porque eu
sempre me perguntava assim nossa mas eu
tô fazendo tudo certo eu tô seguindo
todos esses passos e nunca dá certo é
tudo que eu tava fazendo não era
suficiente
é bom e compartilhando isso aqui com
vocês não pude deixar de pensar na
sociedade que vivemos hoje
na qual nós valorizamos ali as pessoas
mais pelo que Elas mostram o que elas
postam do que por quem elas realmente
são
tanto que passamos mais tempo ali com
pessoas nas redes sociais do que com
pessoas no mundo real claro que se
relacionar ali com pessoas reais implica
em a gente não ser correspondido
correspondido ali sempre como a gente
gostaria
Afinal o outro é diferente de você ele
tem perfeição Hoje ele tem falha só que
isso vem sendo uma realidade cada vez
mais difícil de suportar tão difícil que
a nova realidade acaba sendo a virtual
Olá seja uma pesquisa realizada na
universidade de baylor dos Estados
Unidos com mais ou menos ali 453 adultos
que mostrou que 46 por cento das pessoas
que responderam essa pesquisa disseram
que se sentiam desprezados pelo celular
do parceiro da parceira termo que ficou
conhecido como Pub e as consequências
disso foram vínculos cada vez mais
fragilizado as pessoas com
comportamentos cada vez mais anciosos
inclusive o sentimento de apatia e
solidão dentro dos relacionamentos é
algo que vem crescendo cada vez mais o
autor que eu gosto muito chamado bauma
nos Disc na realidade virtual é como se
criássemos um Avatar como o jogo para
viver ali no mundo arma e não se Canario
nós chamamos isso de idealização então
passamos ali mais tempo de vida
investindo numa idealização em que os
casais as pessoas as famílias são
perfeitas corpos mães pessoas Instagram
mas que não são reais e isso acaba
fragilizando os vínculos na no mundo
real ali na realidade Afinal e o em um
universo em que você pode escolher qual
é a sua melhor cara é fácil esquecermos
que temos efeitos e Somos imperfeitos
hoje a verdade aqui olhamos mais para
telas do que para o que realmente
importa
priorizamos mais acompanhar o
desenvolvimento os relacionamentos as
outras pessoas dando likes no Instagram
no que viver o próprio esquecemos que
somos de carne e osso e que nem sempre
podemos estar ali disponíveis e essa
forma de se relacionar é algo que tá
ficando tão sério ou seja As crianças
estão sendo afetadas o outro estudo
realizado pela revista norte-americana
Highline com cerca de 1520 crianças ali
de 6 a 12 anos mostrou o quinto 62 por
cento dessas crianças
achavam que os pais estavam distraídos
demais para escutá-lo e acreditem o
celular foi apontado como a maior fonte
de distração
aqui no Paraná inclusive surgiu a
campanha conecte-se ao que importa pelo
programa de dica para poder estimular as
relações ali reais entre pais e filhos a
verdade aqui o julgamento entre o mundo
real e os vínculos nos faz cada vez mais
nos preenchermos por telas produtos
estilos de vidros que não damos conta de
sustentar e que às vezes não precisamos
e não é espaço ali para criarmos algo
que seja nosso que não seja padronizado
não é um tédio Brasil precisamos estar
sempre ali postando para sermos
lembrados o tempo todo assim como eu no
exemplo que eu contei para vocês que
achava que tinha que estar sempre
presente nos encontros para não
esquecerem de mim bom é naquele exemplo
que eu contei para vocês eu pude contar
ali com grandes amigas com muita terapia
e muito tempo para poder entender que eu
tava mantendo toda uma costura uma
aparência de pessoa evoluída e na
atingível mas que na verdade eu estava
fazendo várias coisas ali que me
aprisionavam que me machucavam e que não
faziam sentido para mim mas faz sentido
para uma sociedade que prega que é
melhor você não mostrar quem você
realmente é do que mostrar E com isso eu
perdi muitas possibilidades de me
relacionar com pessoas bacanas e fazer
coisas que eu gostaria e não que
esperavam de mim
né eu quero dizer é que redes sociais
elas não são inteiramente ruim eu não
estou aqui para imunizar lá mas para
podermos refletir e substitui a
realidade por ela e transformarmos ela
como prioridade Isso sim é um problema
que a gente precisa começar a pensar bom
naquele exemplo que eu tava contando
para vocês eu achava que eu não queria
frustrar as pessoas mas na verdade eu
não queria era me frustrar por perceber
que na realidade eu também era uma
pessoa vulnerável e que toda essa defesa
era uma aparência para que o outro não
conhecesse lá no fundo o lado que nem eu
mesma queria conhecer lá do que eu
passei muito tempo Obrigada o lado
humano que erra o prefeito é cheio de
contradições não gosta de todo mundo
sabe quando foi a conclusão de que eu
poderia viver de outra forma ali uma
forma mais verdadeira quando eu pude
desarmar a minha defesa frente a vida
quando eu pude me destituir desse lugar
de aparência de uma pessoa evoluída bem
resolvida claro que isso não foi um
processo fácil Afinal isso tinha ele
constituído enquanto pessoa mas eu fui
percebendo que em sei aquilo que os
outros esperavam de mim isso aqui eu
gostaria de ser o sofrimento fazia parte
ele era inerente então alguns desarmar
frente a vida eu pude ali ser alguém
real ser alguém possível que eu tava
tudo tava ligando tanto ali para essa
postura né de ser uma pessoa bem
evoluída inatingível que na verdade eu
não estava aproveitando os momentos ali
de Fato né da vida e é
bom eu estou evoluída na verdade podemos
nos questionar aí o que é ser uma pessoa
evoluída
E se o que podemos fazer Aline o que tá
dentro do nosso possível o que a gente
dá conta de fazer
de que não somos 100% sempre não dá para
carregar o mundo e as pessoas nas nossas
costas atrás que eu diria eu estou
tirando ainda o fardo de ter que ser
perfeita na minha vida o que as redes
sociais nos cobre nos reforçam o tempo
inteiro hoje eu penso que estou olhando
mais para o que realmente importa para
mais do que eu gostaria que eu quero
para mim e não que as pessoas esperam de
mim como estamos aí no meio de uma
pandemia não podemos fazer muita coisa
ali no mundo real mas não que eu posso
eu passo uma tarde toda ali brincando de
ser criança com meu sobrinho me
relacionando com pessoas que eu amo
e sem filtro sem edições viver a vida o
amor
relacionamentos de forma mais humana tem
aquele scripts que eu tentava fazer das
relações de transformar em filme algum
roteirizado ali o que tá mais para uma
poesia que nem sempre tem rima Nem só de
coisas boas da vida é feita assim como
as relações humanas
mas precisamos aí normalizar que não
estarão o tempo inteiro não é algo ruim
seu número de curtidas ou visualizações
seja no Instagram YouTube não dita o
quanto você amado ou quem você é de que
o virtual é a realidade de fato quando
sabemos lá no fundo que não é
Há quanto tempo da sua vida você passa
vivendo milhares de outras que não é a
sua tempo não é dinheiro tempo é vida e
o mundo real pode nos frustrar as
pessoas podem nos frustrar Mas eu
continuo apostando que vale mais a pena
do que investir em um outro número que
nos afasta do que importa e de quem
realmente escola eu aprendi que as
pessoas vão te amar vão lembrar de você
por quem você é e não porque você vive
postando algo no Instagram pode ter
certeza que não serão mil amigos ali que
você terá mas às vezes 5 10 que vale
muito mais a pena para compartilhar a
vida as relações que forem reais Elas
irão se sustentar nas imperfeições e nas
falhas
e os relacionamentos os filhos não serão
aqueles de Instagram mais um real que
tem conflitos e que nem sempre está bem
Tá bom mas aí é com vocês o que
realmente importa está nas redes sociais
ou está bem aí na sua frente
muito obrigada